joining us to decode the media freaked
out upon the release of the Muller
report as well as the avenatti news was
sort of a Monday's follies twisted
Raymond Arroyo author of the brand new
book will Wilder the amulet of power
Raymond now you were closely watching
the immediate media reaction when the
bar letter dropped on Friday now Laura I
I think we can safely call this the
Muller meltdown okay as time went on
some of these media icons they regained
their footing and they started spinning
new narratives but as the bar letter
dropped live and they absorb the reality
of it and what it meant their reactions
were telling this is Chris Matthews no
further indictments no charges against
the president why it was there never an
interrogation of this president how can
they lead Trump off the hook
you know Laura the emotional attachment
was so severe here in the case of Chris
Matthews as he saw the narrative
slipping away you see him visibly
overcome with anger anger rushes in if
Bryan Cranston wants to leave Network on
Broadway Chris Matthews might be able to
fill in with him for the evening or for
him now Rachel Maddow also had a rough
night that evening on MSNBC it was
shocking devastating to MSNBC's
narrative so Matt out decide to focus I
did to focus not on the letter but on
the process of delivering the letter
watch a Justice Department staffer or
messenger of some kind all we know is
that she was wearing a North Face jacket
brought in fact two letters to the
committee in two separate manila
envelopes the Democratic congressman
Jerry Nadler was at his New York office
he was not in DC so the committee staff
quickly made a digital copy and and got
the letter to him that way North Face
jacket it's unbelievable that she never
really got to the marrow of the thing
until halfway through the show the
ladies at the view just a few months ago
Laura were singing an impeachment song
all their own listen
but today they were a little less
jubilant Laura especially about the
exoneration of the president no evidence
that the guy in the White House
conspired with Russia what what about
what happened there a little question I
don't buy that he's completely
exonerated we're gonna look that one up
Laura do you have your thesaurus working
on